[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here
and this is something that we've been
waiting for
for a pretty long time ever since over a
year ago when microsoft sort of
pre-announced that they're working on a
foldable
android surface phone
this is what we're waiting for now it's
finally here so this
is the microsoft surface duo and this
this will be the first time i've held it
since those initial pre-unveilings now
right from the top this is just an
impressions video and there's again a
limitation of what i'm allowed to show
here
and it's very specific i can't turn it
on
until the full review so this is going
to be a shorter video but i just wanted
to talk for a second about
this hardware choice in foldables in
general
and how i think this actually smartly
fits in so in this uh fancy reviewers
kit box here there are some surface
earbuds as well as the duo itself and
there's also a letter from panos
about being one of the first to try the
duo and how excited they all are about
it
of course i'm interested in the duo's
box itself here and
i think this smaller box is what we can
expect people
to actually get when they get the phone
so as we get into it
it's always weird to see it says
microsoft and android on the same box
but that's what's happening here
right at the top you have the device
wrapped in some plastic
[Applause]
so this is it and wow
uh but i'm gonna put it down for a
second because notably also included in
the box we got to show
is a surface duo bumper which is
actually designed to protect the edges
of this
razor thin foldable and you also get
your paperwork
you get an 18 watt power brick and you
get
a usb type-c cable okay so my first
impressions of this thing just holding
it are
wow this thing is thin this is an
incredibly thin piece of hardware holy
smokes
and it feels great to hold so i think a
reason by microsoft is limiting this
whole
first impressions thing to just hardware
only is because the hardware
first impression experience all around
is
super super positive with this whole
tablet phone thing whatever we're
calling it
now i think once you turn it on and you
get a load of those bezels
and you start using the last year specs
and the not so impressive camera i think
that's when you start to fall back down
to earth
about the whole thing but there's no
denying this is a
super impressive piece of hardware the
whole outside of this thing is glass
not metal like other surface products so
it is shiny as you can see reflections
from it but since it's white you don't
really see many fingerprints
and there is no screen on the outside
it's just a microsoft logo under the
glass
on the front and nothing not even any
cameras
nothing on the back so clean all the
buttons are on the right side so the
volume rocker
the power button and then a fingerprint
reader which doubles as kind of like a
pry point to open the surface duo like a
laptop
that's all on the right side along with
the sim card tray and on the inside here
you see the camera
up near the earpiece and that flash all
up on the inside plus some other hidden
ambient light and proximity sensors
and from there it's really all about the
hinge
now microsoft making a folding phone to
me
shows that they believe it is the future
in some way
but the important part is they've made
this bet here
on this hinge this is a 360 degree hinge
and i think i said out loud within like
four minutes of taking it out the box
i think this is the nicest hinge i've
ever used in a piece of tech
it is so smooth and firm
and satisfying it's honestly incredible
and i'm including laptops and other
folding phones and everything in this
i think the hinge engineers specifically
for the surface duo here
deserve a round of applause and really
the best part about all this
is it can firmly hold itself up at any
angle that you want
so you can have it halfway open or
completely flat or
anywhere in between really which is
super satisfying
unlike something like a galaxy fold for
example which really just sticks to two
positions which are closed
or locked fully open anything in between
really isn't going to work
and then there's also this little move i
kept seeing in the demo where
if you want to put it flat on a table
there's this thing where you kind of
place it down and then just press in the
middle to get it perfectly flat
and i thought that was nifty it just
ends flat and that's probably why they
didn't want a camera bump on the back of
this thing because
they actually see a lot of people
probably using it while it's just
sitting
on a desk just halfway open a couple
other things i noticed
yes there are magnets inside the surface
duo
potentially for other accessories but i
was just messing around with a surface
pen
and yes it will hold a pen to the back
of the surface duo if you want to
it makes sense i guess to attach it to
the back or the side and a little magnet
paper
reveals where those magnets are and this
does seem like a
perfect form factor for note taking like
writing in a little notebook here so i'm
glad those magnets
are in there and i just i don't know i
really can't get over how thin this
thing is
the usbc port on the bottom right side
is almost
the thickness of the entire half of the
tablet so if you've got a usbc port
around you somewhere take a look at that
that's how thick half of this tablet is
and it actually doesn't feel
flimsy at all as far as like flex when
you really bend
or pry at it and try to twist it i think
that's thanks to the glass sheets on the
front and the back
the only concern i have with the
thinness is just of course how it'll do
with battery you already know not a lot
of internal space
means not a lot of battery and the
surface duo has
battery in both halves that add up to
about 3 600 milliamp hours
and that's for 8.1 inches of total
display
and you know here might as well toss up
the rest of the spec sheet while we're
at it
there is some concern with the older
specs as i've mentioned and i think as
soon as you
really intake that that's when the the
falling back to earth starts to happen
it's an
amazing first impression but you know
i'm gonna turn this thing on and i'm
gonna start using
the last year's specs then i'm going to
have this 60hz
screen and this 11 megapixel camera
which is also
not just a selfie camera but the primary
camera because you flip it around and
take pictures like that
there's nothing on the back so you know
all this is going to start to wear on
you and it's
it's 1400 bucks there's the small
battery there's the no headphone jack
there's
no water resistance there's no wireless
charging
this to me kind of feels it's so first
gen like the galaxy fold was that
i'm almost already considering not
recommending it at all for anyone
because it's not about buying this as a
finished product as much as it is a
proof of concept
and an attempt to see how this idea of a
foldable
works so really the point is everyone
has a different way of attacking
this new frontier of foldables
that we're moving into whether it's lg
with the dual screen case or the
the samsung galaxy fold or the z flip or
this or the royal flex pi everyone does
it
different
and actually think this is a really
smart way to do it
from microsoft in 2020 so basically they
can just build around
this whole dual screen thing for now
right you can have this unique
360 degree hinge which again can't
stress enough how amazing that is
and then you don't have to deal with the
extra thickness and all the problems
that right now
come with the early generation not so
mature tech
of actual folding displays and that's
the stuff that you know samsung and
others will have to deal with
but then sometime in the future after
you're done leaning into the dual screen
thing
you can eventually move the surface duo
to a foldable screen when the tech is
actually good enough
to be this thin i think that's a good
plan it's basically the opposite
of the samsung plan where i love a
galaxy fold but it's going
straight from the infant tech that is
foldable displays
and building a chunky phone around it to
try to
make it work so that's how we ended up
with this and you know that this is just
my first impression of course
the full review of this is coming very
soon make sure to subscribe and hit that
bell if you want to be among the first
to see that when it comes out but
let me know in the comments what you
want to know about using
a phone like this is it a phone a phone
tablet
like this as a daily driver because
that's what i'm going to be doing
i'm going to turn it on now thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace